okay so good morning uh we are doing
monotheism today and I will show you
that the first monotheistic religion is
Christianity and monism actually marks
an intellectual revolution in human
history and it really create the
conditions for modernity okay the lives
we're living today all right so let's
get started and um I want to review
Christianity and why goo so
fast so um if you talk to Christians
they have a very easy and coherent
explanation for why Christianity would
come to dominate Europe okay so let's
let's look at the Christian tradition so
it's called the Christian
tradition which is to say we don't have
much evidence that this is true but this
is what Christians believe and what they
tell each
other all right
so um in the Christian
tradition
Jesus came from Heaven to redeem
Humanity from our evil ways he
sacrificed
himself and after he sacrificed
himself he started a new beginning in
human history he was resurrected and
then he went before his Apostles and
told them to spread the good news the
gospel that he has come and he will
return and then he will bring Paradise
with him okay so there were 12 Apostles
plus Paul and they went all around the
world to spread the good news Paul
became the Apostle to the Gentiles which
meant that um he was trying to bring in
everyone into the new religion of
Christianity to show their
Authority uh and to show that they are
actually the true apostles of Jesus they
are all martyred okay
martydom meaning that you know that they
were telling the truth because they were
persecuted they went to India they went
to uh the lavant they went everywhere to
spread the good news and they interacted
or they challenged the traditional
religious Authority the pagans of that
area and so they were killed okay they
were stoned to death or they were
executed
um and after they died their students
would continue their legacy okay and
these students would become head of the
local church they set up and they were
they became they became known as the
Bishops okay and throughout all this
time uh they were being persecuted by
the Romans and by the pagans but because
of their faith in God and because of the
miracle that is God they would
eventually Triumph and they would and
they would spread for throughout uh
Europe and uh the Middle East and Egypt
until they became a very dominant
Force eventually the Romans said if you
can't beat them join them and the first
Roman Emperor to convert was
Constantine so Constantine uh was the
first Roman Emperor to become a
Christian himself and then a later Roman
Emperor uh would make Christianity the
official Rel religion of the Roman
Empire and this would create the
Catholic
Church the Catholic
Church um is called so because Catholic
means Universal or the one and
only and the Catholic church with the
creation of Catholic Church you had a
new idea called
Orthodoxy or right
thinking and then so one mission of the
Catholic church was to was to combat
heresy or challenging Orthodoxy to make
sure that everyone stayed on the true
path okay and so this is the um official
history told by the Catholic church and
what Christians believe
today but as we discuss in our class
historically that's not what happened
okay so let's go over let's review what
we discuss in this
class
so
Jesus I argued was a religious
genius and he his idea would be what we
call naism today
okay and unfortunately he got unlucky
and he ran into the Roman governor of
Judea called Pontius Pilate
P pilot had a problem he was trying to
enforce the Imperial cult and the
Imperial cult basically just means to
think of the Emperor as God and so think
of a Cod of Personality his pictures his
statues were everywhere including coins
and the Jews hated that because for them
that went against their religion okay
the first commandment is you should have
no God before me Yahweh uh you shall not
worship false gods and so punish pilot
was having a very tough time dealing
with the Jews he threatened the Jews and
the Jews said well if you don't if you
don't get rid of this religious cult
then you have to come kill all of us
okay and so P pilot had to back down he
lost faith and he killed Jesus he
crucified Jesus as basically a middle
finger to the Jewish
people right but because he did that
what he didn't expect is it would make
Jesus into a national hero a martyr and
so um his
followers became called the poor of
Jerusalem okay they established a church
in Jerusalem and they were supported by
the Jewish leaders and they were called
the poor of Jerusalem they were led by
um Jesus Jesus's brother James the
just these people will eventually become
the ebionites okay this is important for
us because the ebionites will eventually
spread to Arabia where they will help
develop a new religion called Islam okay
so from the imites we will develop a new
religion called
Islam the poor got a very got along very
well with the Jewish people because they
just saw themselves as a branch of
Judaism as following the law of Moses
but in a more um but in a manner that
conform to what how Jesus saw World
okay then you had a man named Paul and
Paul was a Roman citizen and he was part
of the Roman Elite and he had a problem
he was part of the Jewish diaspora and
because of the religious fanaticism in
Jerusalem that's was creating conflict
between the Romans and the Jewish
diaspora the Jews believe the Romans
were evil and eventually uh a messiah
will emerge from the ranks from the
house of David who will lead them in the
final Victory against the
Romans so Paul saw Jesus as an
opportunity
to basically divorce the Jewish diaspora
from uh the M Messianic Jews okay that's
why he created uh Proto Christianity
because what he believed what he taught
is Jesus is the Messiah but rather than
a prophet of War he's Propet of
peace and so he basically offered
opportunity for members of the Jewish
diaspora to assimilate themselves into
Roman society if you consider yourself
Jew a a Jew then you believe in the
Messiah who return and fight against
Romans but if that but if you believe
that then eventually Romans might come
and kill you okay so what Paul said is
if you believe in Jesus you can still be
Jewish
because Jesus was Jewish and this is a
Jewish religion but you will be part of
the Roman Empire now rather than part of
just this very parental religion but
what's really important for us to
understand is most people refuse to
follow
Paul okay only very small minority
people actually follow Paul most people
who believe in Jesus were following the
aites okay there's also other groups of
people who believed in uh Jesus for
example the gnostics which we discussed
before and also um you had these mystery
Cults mystery Cults mystery Cults were
the most popular form of religious
worship which which meant they were just
like small groups of people who
practiced the religion
secretly
and um what made these mystery Cults
special was they focus on group
religious
devotion and
worship and they were trying to achieve
a sense of Oneness Unity they're trying
to be Garian they're trying to be uh
anti hierarchical
okay and what made them uh interesting
was they use psychedelics a lot okay
they use drugs a lot in in order to
achieve um a spiritual uh sense and a
lot of them start to believe in Jesus
because
um um Jesus could be easily incorporated
into a religion okay so you have these
different uh early Christian groups
around but what we know is that
eventually Paul's Group which again is
the smallest of these groups would
eventually
Triumph okay the question then is why
why is it that Paul's Church um which
was the smallest of all these different
denomination of early Christianity why
would they early why would they Triumph
in the end okay first of all the
dominant group were obviously James a
just and the poor right well what
happened was this from
66 to 73 CE okay the Romans fought a
major war with the
Jews and over and during this war three
things happened okay the first thing
that happened
was uh the temple was burned down
remember the temple is important because
it is the site of religious worship for
the Jewish people it's the equivalent of
Mecca today so when Jews in the diaspora
when they prayed they prayed in the
direction of the
temple well now have a problem because
the temple has been burned down so now
you have to redefine what it means to be
a Jewish person and as it happened Paul
had a new definition of what it meant to
be Jewish person you believe in Jesus as
Messiah rather than make sacrifices at
the temple
okay second thing that that happened
that was very convenient for Paul in the
Romans was James and his group were
wiped out okay not everyone was killed
but the majority of them were wiped
out their denomination in Jerusalem was
targeted and they were extinguished okay
so this is important because remember
the major authority figure at this time
is James ajust he because he's the
brother of Jesus if he's dead there's no
more Authority therefore Paul can claim
as he does to be the real
Authority
Okay the third thing is that's important
is that basically scares the Jewish
diaspora it scares members of the Jewish
diaspora and a lot of them now see
Paul's Church as a
very good
alternative they're afraid of what
they're afraid that the Romans might
Target the diaspora and so to show their
allegiance to the
Romans but still to to but they still
want to maintain the Jewish identity so
a lot of them start to join Paul's
church not a great deal okay but an
increasing
number this would just start one of
three major Wars between the Romans and
the Jews okay there would be two more
major Wars and both both Wars a lot of
Jews would would get killed a lot would
get enslaved and this would drive more
participation into Paul's Church okay so
a lot of Jews were now joining Paul's
church because of these wars the church
was seen as an
escape mechanism for dibur Jews from
these wars okay does that make sense
okay all
right the other thing about Paul's
church and why became dominant is it
mirror it mirrored the social structure
of the Roman Empire all right so the uh
Roman Empire the social structure is
called the P familias and this is
basically the idea of patriarchy there's
one man the father who is in charge of
the entire household and the household
is basically a small Empire onto itself
okay you have the immediate family okay
um so you you have the sons the children
you also have um the free man okay so
these are slaves who are freed to work
in the household and then you have the
slaves okay so they were in charge of
their own household but they also had
clients okay the client the patron
client
relationship in Chinese we call this
like TI right so someone who would
sponsor your
business and the goal of Roman society
was to have as many clients as possible
because this gave you the idea of fa
okay or what what in at that time was
called
digas
digas right social Prestige the more
clients you had the more people who
obeyed
you the more dignoti you had
okay so the Paul's church was a
hierarchy as well
Mal on the P familias okay so at the at
the top was the
bishop okay and the bishop was in
something called
Dogma which is like how Jesus is to be
understood this is important because the
problem with most early Christians is
they were egalitarian which meant that
you could have your own interpretation
of
Jesus but in this church which is
hierarchal only the bishop or the person
in charge had the right interpretation
and you had to follow his
interpretation and this allowed the
church to scale out into other churches
right but much more important
importantly after you reach a certain
size it made sense for the church to
participate in the patron client
relationship of the perto familias which
meant that they would now invite a local
Aristocrat to become the bishop and if
that would happen the local Bishop would
then convert his entire network and
become Christian right
and and the the Aristocrat would agree
to do this because it allowed him to
more quickly scale out and expand his
Patron client Network the church became
a mechanism for him to expand his social
network and political
power
eventually Christianity would reach a
point where it actually challenged the
authority of the emperor himself right
because remember throughout history the
nobility was always in conflict with the
king the
emperor and now that the nobility was
able to better organize because of the
structure of the church the emperor saw
it as a problem so there were some
persecutions local persecution not not
Global not emperial persecutions of
Christians there were some local
persecutions of Emperors because of the
power struggle right but
eventually emerged an emperor named
Constantine and he had fought a very
bitter Civil War in order to
reclaim uh the the throne and as we know
from our history from our reading of
History great
Kings always want to introduce new
religions to consolidate their their
their Authority okay
so think of um King David introducing
the new religion of Judaism think of um
Augustus introducing the inad to the
Roman
people okay so Constantine wanted to
introduce a new religion to unify the
Empire and to consolidate his his
authority and that became the Christian
religion that's why he converted to
become
Christian and so he began to
sponsor the be beginning of something
called the Catholic church and guess
what he was the first pope the or the
head of the Catholic Church the first
head of the Catholic
Church
okay but now that you have a Catholic
Church you now have the idea of
Orthodoxy okay
Orthodoxy and that's a problem because
remember throughout this history there
are many Divergent forms of Christianity
and so the Catholic Church became began
a process of eliminating all its
competitors until it became the the most
dominant but the problem with
Orthodoxy is
that a lot of Christian history is made
up this is made up on the spot and so
there are lot of
contradictions the major contradiction
one of the major problems in
Christianity is
okay um Jesus came from Heaven to
sacrifice himself right so what is the
relationship between God and Jesus like
who is Jesus real okay and this is a
fundamental
problem in Christianity it was it was
fun fundamental problem back then and it
still remains a fundamental problem
today okay so throughout this time
there have been different solutions
different theories proposed to solve
this problem what's the relationship
between God and
Jesus there's also something called the
Holy Spirit which we haven't really
discussed okay but think of the Holy
Spirit as the expression of God on Earth
so when God wants to do something on
Earth for example he wants to move this
table he does it through the Holy Spirit
okay so the H holy spirit is the
expression of God on Earth it's what
interact with when we pray we pray to
the Holy Spirit rather than rather than
to God
okay so there have been major different
theories proposed to explain the
relationship between
god um the Holy Spirit and Jesus okay so
let let's look at them the first theory
is called
modelism modelism and it's the idea
that
God Jesus and the Holy Spirit
of the same
being but they are in different modes
okay so the metaphor is think of
water if it's really cold water becomes
ice if it's really hot water becomes
Vapor now water ice and Vaper are the
same being but they're in different
forms and that's the idea of modalism
Jesus God and the Holy
Spirit are the same thing but they
expressed differently in different
times okay but this is logical but this
creates a problem because if you
actually read the Bible you will see
some passages where Jesus prays to God
right that doesn't make any sense
because why would you pray to yourself
all right so it's not it's it's a theory
but it's not a great
Theory another theory that's popular is
called
partialism partialism and the idea is
that God Jesus and the Holy Spirit are
parts of a higher being so think of the
ocean right there's one ocean that
covers the entire planet but has
different parts for example there's a
Pacific Ocean there's the Atlantic Ocean
there's the Indian Ocean okay and that's
the idea here where God Jesus and the
Holy Spirit are just parts of a higher
being but then the question then becomes
then what is this higher being okay so
again this makes sense it's not a great
but it's not a great Theory okay the
last Theory I want to talk about is the
idea of
arianism and Iris was created by by um a
religious teacher named Aras and his
understanding was look if God created
Jesus
then that means god came before Jesus
which means which means God has to be
superior to Jesus okay so God is a
higher
being than Jesus Jesus is still great
but God is the superior being okay and
again not great okay but it makes sense
all
right so there's this huge controversy
as
to the nature of God and the nature of
Jesus
and so what Constantin does is in 325
CE he orders all the Bishops of the
Roman Empire to converge in a place
called nessia okay the C of
nessia and during this conference they
have to figure out what the nature of
God is okay so these are all the bishops
from the various
churches and the four major churches of
course are Rome Alexandria Antioch and
jus
M and they're all there trying to figure
out what the nature of Jesus and the
Holy Spirit and God are okay and this is
a solution and this is a solution that
even today no one really can figure out
okay but but this is a solution there
are three beings God Holy
Spirit and
Jesus they are
not the same thing they're separate
they're not equal okay these are three
different
entities
but they're all
God okay this called The Holy Trinity
and this is the major idea underlying
Christianity
Today God G Jesus and holy spirit are
not the same thing they're not equal but
they're all God okay this is called the
godhead all
right so let's try to figure figure out
what's going on here why why do they
pick this
Theory
okay first of all what we what we need
to understand
is these first three theories modalism
partialism and ironism are really
stories okay they're stories of who God
is this the godhead is an
equation Okay now what's the difference
well in a
story you can personalize it you can put
yourself into the story and you can talk
to God and therefore you can
interpret the story The the way you want
to interpret it and therefore you can
argue about the story with others right
that's what stories do but you can't do
that do that in an equation like how do
you put yourself into this equation you
don't belong
anywhere right the system is closed off
to you you're excluded from
it you can't enact with the
godhead therefore you cannot
argue here you understand there's no
room for argument there's no room for
interpretation and argument okay there's
no room for debate that's the first
major advantage of the godhead you
cannot debate anything because there's
nothing to debate you either accept it
or you don't accept it there's no in
there's nothing in between okay second
thing um is
before we understood Faith as something
that you experience
personally you can talk to God you can
feel God but with a godhead it's
something that you have to believe okay
you have to believe in
miracles which forces the idea of Faith
as blind
obedience yeah do you understand faith
is something that you have to before the
godhead Fai is something that you have
to experience for yourself now now Faith
is just blind obedience you have to
accept this as it is you have to
memorize it okay it's like mathematics
when you go to math class you're not
asked to figure out why the proofs work
you have to just memorize the
proofs
right and the third thing about the
godhead is it's
exclusionary meaning exclusionary just
means that you can't put any other
theories in here now if you look at
these three theories moralism partialism
and nism you can actually put them
together okay they're not contradicting
each other they're not fighting against
each other they're different but you
actually put them together whereas with
this
equation it's exclusionary it cannot you
cannot put any other theories into it
and you cannot put this into any other
theories
all
right and so what this means is this if
you put these three things together
something that you have to accept you
cannot debate it something that forces
your blind obedience something that is
exclusionary okay it creates a new idea
in human history called
monotheism okay
monotheism and this is a new new radical
idea in human history never before could
we imagine something called
monotheism there before there were some
religions with one God
right but this one God would also
interact with other
gods or this one God would create new
Gods but the idea of
monism is there's only one God and
that's
it and this is radical in human history
so let's try to figure out monism okay
and by the way monism it's I think it's
a very hard idea to understand so it's
okay if we don't really understand it
today but over the next few months as we
explore the impact of monotheism on
society we'll we'll have a better
understanding of okay all right so let's
look at monism the first thing
understand about monism is if we
memorize this formula and you're forced
to memorize this formula your
understanding reality changes okay and
there's only one way to understand
reality that makes this
true the understanding is
this God is
nothing and
everything okay does that make sense
there's only one way that reality is
structured that makes this statement
true God is Holy Spirit and Jesus but
God is Not Holy Spirit and Jesus and the
understand of reality is God is nothing
and
everything okay meaning God is
everywhere and nowhere at the same
time meaning that God is all
reality what this tells us is
this
symbols become reality
okay the symbols of reality the
represent representation of reality
becomes
conflated okay into reality
itself and then if we do
that this creates three new ideas that
become the underlying basis of modernity
okay and these three new ideas
are
capitalism science
and the nation
state before we didn't have these three
ideas capitalism science and the nation
state but now we
do because we have come to believe that
symbols are reality we have come to
believe that God is nothing and
everything
okay so let's ex let's let's look at
this
okay what is the underlying basis of
capitalism money
right
okay so let's talk let's talk about
money okay because I think money is the
best way to understand this idea that
God is nothing and
everything so you and I go back in
time and we ask the people there what is
the basis of wealth in your Society and
they might
say gold or
silver and we ask why is that the case
why is gold and silver the basis of
wealth in your society and they say well
because gold is beautiful you can make
jewelry out of it also it's very hard to
get gold if they go M it and it's very
hard to mine it and also it's rare
okay so you're like okay that makes
sense yeah gold can be the Bas of wealth
okay now let's imagine some people from
a thousand years years ago they
transport they they uh to our classroom
okay and they ask ask us the same
questions what's the basis of wealth in
your society and we say money and then
they ask what is money and then we say
well money are you know paper that the
government
prints and then they're like okay
but that but wait wait wait wait that
makes no sense because the government
can print as much money as it
wants we're like yeah that's right you
like but and how do you how how can you
trust the government how can you trust
the government not to print
like 20 trillion today how how can you
trust them to behave itself we're like
we don't know
and and they're like then why do you
think money is
valuable do you
understand okay so why do we think money
is valuable because we have we believe
money is
God because money is nothing and
everything because the symbols have
become
reality you
understand okay now the question then
is why do we believe this crap why do we
why do we believe money is God why do we
believe money is valuable because the
power monism is that it destroys other
realities okay it crowds out realities
the first is it symbols reality second
is that it crowds out
realities because before in human
history we believe there were many
realities there was a spiritual
reality there were many spiritual
realities and in the in those realities
money didn't really
matter okay but now with monism we've
destroyed those other realities only the
mature reality
exists but not only that but
for monotheism to work it has
to expand until becomes true it's a self
self filic prophecy okay so aggressive
expansion aggressive
expansionism not
only will expand but it has to destroy
those who criticize it okay so in
society you are not ever allowed to ask
question
wait what if money has no value because
the government can print as much money
as it once you are not allowed to ask
this
question you're not allowed to think of
this question you're not allowed to
imagine the
possibility of this
question okay so that's what monism is
there are three main characteristics of
monism that has enabled it to create the
world
that we live in today okay first is it
destroyed the idea of symbols symbols
are now reality okay money does not
represent wealth money is
wealth second is the idea that it has
destroyed all realities except for the
material reality that we live in today
you are not
allowed
to think of spiritual
realities in school we do not teach the
idea of a spiritual reality even though
in our hearts we know it must exist the
third is the idea of aggressive expans
expansionism it is always expanding
because only by expanding can it be
true and that's why the two major
monistic religions of our time
Christianity and Islam are so violent
okay they're the source of most major
Wars throughout human
history right
so we
think capitalism science and the nation
state all really good things okay but
why let's look at
science science only concerns itself
with the material
reality so you can't see it it doesn't
exist but then this creates a problem
because
science refuses to engage in hard
questions okay one question that I think
is very interesting is what is thought
what is consciousness how do we think
and science the response of science all
to all these questions is don't think
about it it's not a
problem and you're like wait a minute
Consciousness is what makes us human we
can't figure out what Consciousness is
then we will never know what it means to
be human and science responds is a human
being are just the sum of biological
parts
right you are you are just your brain
and your head and your eyes your arms
put
together because that's what what we can
measure but the question of what is
consciousness how do we imagine things
how do we understand things science
doesn't
know and it refuses to engage in this
problem
all
right one more point about
symbols so one thing that you're taught
in school which is not true is we're so
much more sophisticated than ancient
civilizations because ancient
civilizations had these superstitious
beliefs like Gods okay like
Apollo and Athena
and like obviously don't exist so the
fact that these ancient humans believe
they exist demonstrates how stupid they
are but here's the
thing if you go back to these
societies and you were to analyze
thoroughly how they understood apoll and
Athen and other gods you would
understand that they didn't actually
believe these Gods existed okay but they
beli these gods were metaphors and
symbols for forces in
nature that could
influence our Our
Lives okay does that make
sense okay so for example take the idea
of hatred and
Vengeance well hatred and Vengeance
would become m manifested in Gods like
stri life
okay and Nemesis okay Nemesis
strife and the Ancients believed this
was a better way to understand the world
they understood that these forces were
so powerful that we couldn't really
control them therefore we must be
conscious of these forces and control
them better
ourselves and unfortunately today we
believe that because these gods don't
exist they're just symbols then hatred
invention don't really exist either
they're just states of mind they're just
emotions and you can just you can just
pretend they don't exist and then you're
fine okay the word we we use for this is
positive
psychology right have you studied
positive psychology it's the dumbest
idea in the world okay it's the idea
that if you think you're happy then
you're
happy whereas the Ancients thought that
these were external forces and have to
work hard to tame them or to understand
them and I think the Ancients had a much
more thorough and thorough and nuanced
understanding of reality than we
do
okay another idea that we don't have
today is
evil
right the Ancients okay
[Music]
struggled with the idea of evil what is
evil where does it come
from and was a very popular
book um at that time is something called
The Book of
Enoch The Book of
Enoch explains why there was a great
flood remember in the Bible there's this
flood that wipes out Humanity on Noah
survives right so the Book of Enoch
tells a story of why God had to destroy
the
world so after God created the
world um his angels called the Watchers
saw humans and they thought that humans
were stupid and evil so they came down
to better manage us okay but then they
start to lust after after woman and they
start to have children with these women
and the and these created Giants okay
called the ephem the nefem okay sorry NE
neim and these are giants and so we
humans just fought saw them as like Gods
so remember the Epic of gilam mas well
gilam Mas was a
nefem and so we start to make make
sacrifices and pay tributes to these
Giants but over time these Giants became
more and more greedy and so they start
to devour us and fight amongst
themselves and so now God up in heaven
he recognizes his problem and so he
creates a flood to destroy these neem
these Giants okay so now they're wiped
out but because they
are because they are born of angels they
are Immortal and so they become these
evil spirits these evil
spirits that roam around the earth okay
and they try to create
chaos there's one great king called
Solomon
King's David's son and he discovers
these evil spirits and he captures them
with a
ring but these evil spirits recognize
that we as human beings are all flawed
so they tempt him with a beautiful woman
and Solomon wants to have sex with her
but she says to have sex with me you
must worship my God and so Solomon
agrees and he becomes um become he
becomes controlled by these evil
spirits now after monism after the
Catholic Church they banned The Book of
Enoch because obviously if you're a
powerful person you don't want you don't
want orinary people thinking that you
can be tempted by evil if you're an evil
spirit you're going to go tempt powerful
people right because it is the most
advantage to you and the powerful people
are most easy people to tempt because
they love power
right so so today we're not we're not
allowed to ask the question e about evil
where does evil come from why are people
evil you're not allowed to think of
think it
okay so
monism is crying out different realities
and possibilities from us and we live in
a world that I
think is I think we live in a world that
even though we are much more wealthy and
technologically advanced we are much
less
sophisticated
than
um than
in historical times all right so let me
conclude by summarizing what we
discussed and
explain what monism
is and
the consequences on our lives because of
monism
okay okay so the first thing
is back throughout most of human history
we humans believe that gods are
everywhere every day we're interacting
with Gods because we believe in
spiritual realities okay so and again
gods are
metaphors so this is
premar this is Martyr
now what do we believe we believe that
money is
God we structure our lives around the
idea of money why do we come to school
to get good grades so that we can get a
university why because we need a job to
make money why because buying things
will make us happy okay that's what
everyone believes God is money money is
God and the ultimate consequence of this
for in our lives is
life is
alienating think about the number of
depressed people in the world depression
is a new idea it didn't exist
before think about the number of people
who live depressing Lives who are
unhappy who are angry who
are who just hate themselves in their
lives
okay second thing that we believe
throughout most most of human history is
spiritual
reality is
real okay there's a higher plane there
are higher Dimensions there are the
spirits who roam in these Dimensions
when we die we will enter these
spiritual Realms and therefore we must
prepare for entry into the spiritual
Realms by living spiritual lives on
Earth okay spiritual reality is real now
today we only believe that material
reality is
real and only material reality is real
when we die we're nothing we came from
nothing we live our lives then we die we
become nothing that's pretty
depressing okay so what this means for
our society is
facts matter more than
truth in school you learn facts you
don't learn truth it doesn't make sense
in science class you're learning facts
you're not learning truth there's a huge
difference facts are things that happen
in the world truth is how the world
works there's a difference you don't
learn how the world Works in science
class you just learn things that happen
in the world that happen to be true
right the last major consequence is this
premodern we believe that
slavery was the worst
evil
okay if you believe in spiritual
realities and you believe that when you
die you will just Ascend to the
spiritual realm then you want to live
your best life on Earth you don't want
you don't want to be a Slave
but now what are you taught you're
taught dying
death is the worst evil the worst thing
that can happen to you
is dying and death because when you die
you become
nothing so what does this mean it
means we are all
slaves okay if you're afraid of dying
you can't live your best life life
you're not going to take risk you're not
you're not going to ask questions you're
not going to explore we are all slaves
every one of us because we are afraid to
die
okay and you think about it monotheism
oh sorry monotheism is what creates the
world we live in today and what and what
and how and and it explains why we live
the lives we do today
all right now what's important for us to
understand is this is
not an instant change okay this is
something that will have to be fought
over for about a thousand years because
monotheism this godhead it is such a
strange idea that people refuse to
believe it this is a minority religion
at that time but again because this is a
religion that must expand it will
eventually Triumph and create the world
we live in today but only by killing
millions and millions of people in these
religious wars so from the first day
from the day the Catholic church was
built it was engaging in Crusades and
inquisitions against people who refuse
to believe in this
Orthodoxy
right okay so I know this was a lot to
take in all right but are there any
questions that you
have that's
right okay so um I'm I argue that we are
less sophisticated than before because
before everyone was very intuitive and
very imaginative meaning that they could
imagine themselves living in different
realities at the same time right there's
a physical reality that you experience
but then there's also this high
dimension the spiritual reality that you
could
feel okay so for
example um if I were to fight with you
okay if we had a fight I would
experience that but I could also see
maybe this God behind me pulling my
strings and the god behind you pulling
your strings as well
okay so when you read The Iliad uh there
are all these other realities that exist
on top of each other the reality that we
live but also the a higher reality where
the gods negotiate amongst themselves
and again this is a metaphor a symbol
for the structural forces that govern
the
universe does that make
sense all right so so when I mean
sophisticated I really mean much more in
itive and much more imaginative
than uh than we are
today okay what made us lose the ability
to imagine right okay well um it's these
three things really capitalism science
and the nation state right do you
understand because with capitalism what
it teaches us is that money is the only
good the highest good so it crows on
other things like for example um love of
each other
interconnectedness right if you if you
are a mother who loves your child guess
what it doesn't matter but if you think
about it the most beautiful thing in the
world is a mother loving her
children but because of capitalism we're
taught that doesn't exist because you
cannot financially
exploit it you can't measure it okay
then you look at
science science is the ultimate
religion
because everyone believes it has to be
true it's
objective but what you will
learn um next semester okay we won't do
this semester but we what what we will
learn next semester is the idea of
objectivity okay objectivity
it doesn't
exist and this is something proven okay
this is something that Elite scientists
know but which no one else but like
which we don't really understand object
objectivity doesn't
exist all right in fact what Elite
scientists now know and this is a very
strange idea we will explore next
semester is the universe reality it is a
collective
um it is a collective
hallucination do you understand we we'll
Le this next semester okay but the idea
is that the universe is what we imagine
it to
be it doesn't exist on its own does that
make sense okay but we believe it exists
on its own because of
science right so when you go to science
class you think you're learning the
truth prove but you're actually learning
a
religion that um hinders you from
imagining other
realities okay and of course the nation
state the nation state now is like God
right who are you well you're you are a
Chinese citizen but before we didn't
think like that we just saw ourselves as
members of a
community and it could be a global
Community okay and you could have many
identities but now if you're a Chinese
citizen you're not an American citizen
because you're in competition with each
other does that make
sense so these are the three underlying
ideas of the reality we live in
today and this wasn't true
before okay I so this a hard hard idea
to understand but next semester become
clear and clearer
okay any any more questions
okay all right so um good